good morning Hank it's Tuesday I was
duly awed by your epic and encyclopedic
rant about punishments and so even
though I still believe in my heart that
I do not owe a punishment I'm going to
do one because data does not lie well
sometimes it does but it lies less than
your heart that's what today's video is
kind of about actually okay so my
favorite character in this summer's book
club pick behind the beautiful forevers
is Sunil the 12 year old garbage picker
who grew up in an orphanage in fact
we're told those who neo was not an
orphan he understood that phrases like
AIDS orphan and when I was the second
hand woman to mother Theresa helped
sister Paulette the nun who ran the hand
mades of the Blessed Trinity Children's
Home get money from foreigners by the
way a little recommendation when you
have a four-year-old child don't take
books to the beach so anyway that's the
first mention of charity and behind the
beautiful forevers and boy is it
complicated tsuneo is a non orphan in an
orphanage sister Paulette lies to raise
money and we later when the orphanage
collects clothes for the kids and then
sells those clothes to pay for other
stuff so all Sunil isn't an orphan he
does need the orphanage plus he learns
to read while he's there and that's the
kind of non straightforward story about
charities both domestic and
international that we rarely hear
especially from charities themselves
right because they have to raise money
and telling people how we think this is
gonna go well it isn't going to be
perfect but we suspect it will be in
that positive although there's no way to
know that's a terrible fundraising
strategy but that's closer to the
reality that we see in behind the
beautiful forevers like the charity
administered school in dona Watty is
taught by a teenager and definitely
substandard and toward the end of the
book we learned that many charity
administered schools are outright frauds
when a new school opened in the pink
temple by the sewage lake many children
gravitated to it but it closed as soon
as the leader of the nonprofit had taken
enough pictures of children studying to
secure government funds and then they're
like collaborations between government
and charity which are also sometimes
problematic like you'll remember that on
Audis political representative who is
super corrupt keeps getting public
amenities care of the charity World
Vision you know why public toilets and
gutters and etc and that's all good
stuff but it's timed to the election so
that he can keep his power and so you
could see it as these projects like
further institutionalizing the corrupt
power system right but then again good
toilets are really important for public
health it's complicated hey this is all
particularly interesting to me right now
because as you watch this i am in east
africa learning about some of the work
that people there are doing with the
help of the Gates Foundation
now this is
in East Africa is vastly different from
the situation in Hawaii but around the
world including in our own neighborhoods
we need to look at what charities do and
how well they do it and you don't to be
giving to charity simply because it
makes you feel booter because it lessens
some guilt that you have we want to
actually decrease worldsuck I apologize
for splitting that infinitive but I felt
that it was necessary when we talk about
health and poverty we are talking about
incredibly complicated problems that yes
money can be Mis allocated and it can be
used to bolster corrupt regimes but we
have lots of data links in the dooblydoo
showing that in the last twenty years
when people have access to the right
resources and tools they can transform
the health and economic opportunities in
their communities rising income better
food security higher literacy rates
lower infant mortality those aren't
anecdotes and they are real progress
take one of the reasons I continue to
reread behind the beautiful forevers is
that it doesn't contain any unambiguous
victories not for the character
certainly but also not for foreign aid
or government spending or microfinance
or charity nonprofit spending doesn't
always work partly because not all
nonprofits are equally effective and
partly because no one succeeds all of
the time I think when trying to figure
out what does work data is probably
ultimately a better guide than anecdote
but then again data can also be
manipulated Hank we are either going to
embrace complexity or we're going to be
lying to ourselves that's what I took
away from behind the beautiful forevers
I look forward to reading your thoughts
in comments when I return Hank I hope to
learn a lot this weekend hope to listen
a lot but if I come home with
straightforward answers and simple
solutions I am probably doing it wrong
okay Hank although I will be very
jet-lagged I will see you on Friday